i'm paul north
i'm a professor in the german department
at yale and i'm not a tv personality or
a producer
so we're just technologically
and in terms of this medium flying by
the seats of our pants
our collective pants so you'll forgive
us if it
isn't perfect these are the frankie
lecturers and the humanities
at the whitney humanities center this
series is called the value of marx's
capital you'll get
a little bit of a play on words there
the series is a companion to an
undergraduate seminar at yale
which is on marx's capital volume one
and it also is in conjunction with a new
english translation of capital volume
one done by my colleague
and collaborator on this paul ryder from
osu
who's here i'm co-editing it but paul is
doing
a really sparkling crisp and rigorous
translation which will be out with
princeton university press in a couple
of years so we're taking the opportunity
to
work through the book with students and
bring in
uh luminaries to go through it with us
i have to give a couple of thanks first
the frankie lectures are made possible
by the generosity of richard and barbara
frankie
and are intended to present important
topics in the humanities to a wide and
general audience
i'd like to thank alice kaplan the
director of the whitney humanities
center
who was behind this project from the
beginning
and is taking the center in amazing
directions
sandra malone bowles who coordinates it
from the whitney
liana hirschfeld crowen who did all of
the organizing work
i thank her and audrey leake who is our
technical
whiz kid let me say a couple of things
about how the workshop
will run for all of you here and also
for the students in the seminar
professor musta will give a presentation
with some breaks in it where we'll have
some conversations
after that there'll be a q a starting
with the students in the seminar just to
give them
a chance to get their questions in and
then we'll open up the floor to
questions from anybody who
has them let me ask you though not to
post your questions until i give the
signal they will simply get lost in the
chat
so we'll ask you to put them in the chat
in the q a
i will give a signal first to the
students in the seminar they can ask
their questions and then i'll open it up
and we'll try to get to all of your
questions in the chat
if you need to leave or you can't make
another of these sessions
that you're interested in they're being
recorded they will show up on the
whitney humanities center website
about two weeks after the workshop we
hope
also i want to say just doing all this
business
that if you want to register for
subsequent workshops
you can only register the week before so
keep your eyes out for that
one important act today
i think maybe the most important is to
reassess
our vocabulary of revolution
marcelo musto has become the emcee of
this reassessment
the ringmaster i think of an enormous
and enormously careful return to marx's
texts
as sources for new understandings of
vocabulary we think we understand
he's going to talk about one of those
words today
i want to start each of these with a
quote from the author
here's a quote from an article on
communism by marcelo musto
quote the alternative to capitalist
alienation was achievable
only if the subaltern classes became
aware of their condition
as new slaves and embarked on a struggle
to radically transform the world
in which they were exploited their
mobilization
and active participation in this process
could not stop however
on the day after the conquest of power
it would have to continue
in order to avert any drift towards the
kind of state socialism that marx always
opposed
with the utmost tenacity and conviction
a moment of musto's prose now i'd like
to
turn the microphone over to my
collaborator paul ryder who's a
professor of german
at ohio state who will intro introduce
professor musto
thanks paul and welcome uh professor
musto it's such a pleasure to
to welcome you to our series uh marcelo
musto is a professor of sociology
at york university in toronto
one of his most recent publications is
entitled
the marx revival and interestingly
subtitled
new concepts and interpretations or key
concepts excuse me and interpretations
and this
speaks to what paul was just saying
about his his interest
in engaging very rigorously with
particular categories
um today rereading them reassessing them
um
and we see that in his work on on
alienation as well
um if you've read the article that was
disseminated on alienation you know that
he writes with tremendous very edition
and clarity enviable really um and
uh to come back to this uh this title
that i just mentioned the mark's revival
uh there is a mark's revival and
uh professor musto is doing truly more
than
any other scholar i can think of to to
advance it he's
in addition to the qualities that i just
mentioned he's incredibly prolific he's
given over 50 interviews in recent years
written over 50 newspaper articles
and also this list of publications is
much too long
to to go through in its entirety but to
mention
just a few things he's edited on
anthologies
on uh capital 150 years later
he has a massive anthology in the in the
works
on uh or handbook really
on the global dissemination of
capital and trent and the history of of
translations of capital
around the globe he's also offered
many books as well most recently
uh the uh or many single author books as
well
most recently the last years of karl
marx which uh
just appeared in the spring i believe
and uh is really a marvel of of
compactness it's a
biography of marx's last years
archivally very rich
conceptually very interesting uh not not
very long
either really it's a great deal for the
reader
and i'd like to mention also that it was
written in italian and came out in 2016
um just around the time that the big
wave of mark's biographies was
starting to really take shape and and
come at us
and it was translated very effectively
let's not forget the translator here by
patrick camiller into into english
so uh it's really wonderful to have
professor musto here
the title of this presentation today is
marx's conception
of alienation thanks for being here
thanks everybody good afternoon good
evening to
all the people who are listening now i
am uh indeed very grateful for your
invitation for your
generous words very very generous words
and um i am very happy to be here with
the
professor north and professor vater i
will
call you paul and paul if i may even
this is the first time that we talk to
each other
and i i'm sure that we are going to talk
about this later but i was
extremely happy when i heard this
fantastic news that capital was going to
have a new translation in english
at this time very important and with
such a prestigious um
publishing house like princeton um
we'll discuss this later but it was um
wonderful to have this news
and to put together this two
um interests for marx like you know the
importance of reading marx very
carefully
my work has been as theological as
possible but at the same time
trying to use what marks right for
understanding um our societies our
issues
it is also a very strange talk for me um
and i will try to make
some jokes it is the first time in my
life that i talk
not being standing like just sitting at
the table because generally i used to
uh stand and i also used to
speak as a young activist at the
university in
naples and italian i was
in italy until then i had to
leave and go to berlin to study english
and then i moved here in toronto in 2009
i would like to start from a couple of
biographical notes if my
host allow me to do this because perhaps
is useful
is interesting for the many students or
researchers who are listening now
so we are in this
period of rediscovery for marx
and um i will introduce a couple of
topics that i hope i will be able to
discuss with paul north and paul vader
and then
later with more people
but when i started to read
about marks um
i have another image now
can you hear me
okay um
we hear you find ourselves now there is
somebody here or somebody
who from the microphone they saw another
face
um when i started to read mark so when i
entered my phd in 2002 in italy
i um was actually the first
uh researcher the first person who was
going to defend the dissertation after
so many years
in such a big and important country for
marxist study like italy
a dissertation in darlian marx and
later when i moved to berlin when i
started to go there and i spent some
time at the
berlin brandenburg academy of shaftan
which is the institute for social
science
where um the new edition the new
critical edition of marx and angus
writing
started in 1998 as we started
i remember that my perception of mark's
change
changed dramatically and one of the
point that i would like to make today
about capital later we will discuss
about this is that
after the mega after this
enterprise that i would present in in a
minute
uh looking at capital like a book of
three volumes this classic
set that i've seen many times in my life
um and comparing these three volumes
with the
15 volumes and this huge
um critical apparatus so every volume in
the mega
is uh 500 700 800 pages of apparatus so
this is the second section of the mega
which is called
capital in its preparatory manuscript
is a big change it's a big change for us
for readers of marx
i will go back to this point um
very soon for the moment i would like to
discuss with you i would like to discuss
with
professor north professor raiter paul
and paul
i would like to put a couple of cards on
the table and the first
question is what kind of revival paul
just said that there is a revival of
interest for marx
we know this revival mostly because of
what happened after 2008
after 2008 one more big economic and
financial crisis
and marx is back in europe in north
america after
20 years of silence practically
so the marks that we are reading is
mostly a marx
that could be you know the critique of
political economy the critique of
capitalism and marx was celebrated on
many important newspaper liberal
conservative it doesn't matter
like the person who is still useful
for us not to understand capitalism
including publishing
some wonderful articles that marx wrote
in 1857 1858 at the time of
another big financial crisis that
started in new york
150 years before the crisis they erupted
in 2008 i remember i was in berlin
buying the frankfurter miner and being
so shocked
of seeing two full pages of you know
reprinting of the
famous article on the economic crisis
that marx wrote for the
new york new york tribune in 1857
but in other parts of the world actually
there was another reading of marx or
another
interest of marx for example in latin
america
marx was rediscovered a few years before
the 2008 crisis and the return to marx
was i would say
more political than the one that we had
in
in europe and in north america with all
the contradictions without the problem
but it was a marx that
was alive and was perceived as something
useful
no something that people will need and
if you ask me after this uh
many years of work of collective work
like trying to
connect young researchers and
institutions universities and
you know try to rediscover marx paul
north
read this
citation at the beginning so it's
clearly a marx that is very different
from the
tradition of marxist lenin in the 20th
century etc
but if you ask me where i've seen the
most interesting things
in in which country i would say that
brazil is definitely the place that
called my attention more than
anywhere else i remember you some people
would be surprised because today
brazil is not the place where there is
the most progressive
government or at the moment there are
not
very strong social movements like in the
past
couple of years but the attention
in the universities and in this research
group that are not
close merely to the university but
they're open to look at the
contradiction in our societies
the attention for marx or for an author
that i also very much like antonio
gramsci but let's just stay to march
today is really impressive right i don't
want to say
give wrong numbers etc but i think that
there are at least
150 centers of research around
marx and marx's studies in brazilian
universities
and when i went there to meet some of
these um
scholars i was impressed by the fact
that many of them were
extremely young so they they belong to
a generation that was actually younger
than
mine and dead new demands that new
enthusiasm that new new topics
and i want to return to this question
new topic because i believe that the
marx that is
read now in the last two three years
and paul writer was very generous when
he described my book
the last years of karl marx but my
effort in the publication of the book
was trying to rediscover
a marx that is very different from the
perception that we have of this author a
perception of an author who has
dedicated his entire life
merely studying or fighting politically
the contradiction between capital and
labor there is
much much more remarks and
i am very happy to see that
a majority i will say of the books of
the studies published in the last two
three years
are opening topics that later were
never or very rarely associated with
marx
for example ecology for example
gender emancipation for example
migration
nationalism colonialism
i believe that there is a lot of marks
that must be discovered and i believe
that the last
part of his life the last 10 15 years
from the international 1864 1872
to the year that marx died in 1883
there is a lot that will be done there
and this is the task of a new generation
of
scholars of researchers of translators
in particular of translator paul
writer because there is a very few of
marks
that has been published in that period
and i hope that we can
discuss this i'm not lost in my thought
but i'm trying to
follow um what i promised so this first
uh
group i've prepared five and the first
one would be a sort of you know the
marks revival today in the world
so i would like to say that i discover
also other kind of revivals for example
in china it is impressive the amounts of
book that were
translated in china in the past
15 20 years not only there is a new
very scholarly rigorous and
serious edition of marx and english
writings the distraught lady also for
the first time
from german and not from russian some
writings of marx but before a little
circulation or
poor translation or a very ideological
reading
but in china there has been also a big
opening to the so-called western marxism
or if you don't like this terminology
to many european and north american
authors
so there is a new generation of chinese
students
in particular in humanities a little bit
in social science and i would say my
experience
not at all in the economics so another
paradox that is repeating now also in
china
that is very interested in marks and
also
in this new reading so i've always seen
china as a place to compete
right as a possibility to enter and also
listening to what these scholars are
doing
are saying so i am the a co-editor of a
series
that is called marx angus marx's new
dimensions
and my most important effort
in terms of editor is translating from
spanish from brazil
portuguese sorry from chinese from
japanese
countries with a very strong and lively
tradition in terms of marxist studies
translate this thing into english
because sometimes um this
readings of marks are different and i
find very interesting to
discuss this different options these
different
ideas of marks um i stop here on this
point
but if i have please uh two more minutes
three more minutes
i would like to come back to the
question of what kind of marks
is read today at university i spend a
lot of time
looking at all the syllabi around the
world
and unfortunately i'm not going to share
good news with you
this is at least my understanding of the
situation in my opinion
i've seen that the marks at today's rape
in many departments of politics
political science in the world is the
marks of
on the jewish question which is a very
brilliant actually writing unfortunately
this writing which is not called the
jewish question but on the jewish
question
is a reply to an article written by
bruno bauer called
jewish question that was never
translated into english
so many times people do not understand
what is the real polemic about and then
there is all the party in favor of marx
the party against marx
marx is doing bad things mark is saying
always the perfect and the right things
but this text it is surely
a text that is not representative allow
me to do this
provocation but i'm sure that my
discussion will understand
it is not representative of marks of
politics
if you want to read marx you have to
read marx at the time of the
international
and why the text is not there because
max at the time of international is a
very complicated a complex
mix of writings documents declarations
speeches that he did with the exception
of the civil war in france
is not easy to combine and have
a clear idea of marx positions if you
look at sociology in the department of
sociology
a big majority of them they read the
german ideology
but today the german ideology you
invited terror carver last week perhaps
he mentioned this i'm not
bothering i'm not taking time with this
but today we know that the german
ideology we know more than before
is not a book it's not the ideological
bible
for historical materialism that the
soviet union adorable created the head
of the institute for
marx angus lenin in 1932
okay so if we read that the pages on the
division of labor in the german ideology
we know that this is just the beginning
of a very long journey
and they cannot be compared with capital
but once again
capital is a complicated thick book
and if you want to extract parts from
there
it is a difficult
task yes
can i ask you please a couple of
questions
um it looks like he is spotlighted
and i'm not showing up i'm not sure
if this is a problem because we want to
make sure that the people who
ask questions or do you all see me when
i'm speaking
oh i do well yeah i just don't see
myself
i wanted to well first i wanted to thank
you for the the picture of a
kind of um textual international
which we hope precedes the fifth or
whatever international is coming
a political international it really is
encouraging for people who
read these things to know how much is
going on
also for the picture of a
reconfiguration of the corpus
which is an interesting phenomenon and i
think we all need to say
where to start reading marks where to go
next
what for what pitfalls to
to ignore i wanted to ask you though in
this
world flowering of marx studies and in
the reconfiguration of the corpus
what role does alienation play
in that we're going to talk about
alienation today
is it a hot button issue is everyone
worried about
alienation where should it fit in the
new program
thanks and when i talk
too much like when i pass the 12 minutes
and more or less
we are located for each block i would be
very grateful if you or paul raider you
just
stopped me very politely as you did but
you
helped me to move forward surprisingly
i want to discuss i want to answer
briefly
shortly and then i will expand this
surprisingly
even though um alienation is a topic on
which
there were so many books written in the
60s in the 70s
and alienation was
[Music]
i would say as relevant as the topic
globalization has been for
us in the in the past two decades right
really everybody wrote about alienation
and
i can think in the 60s and in the 70s
in many disciplines in sociology in
politics in
psychology literature
a few terms at the fortune of
alienation and marx alienation mark
conception of alienation which is the
title of my
talk my contribution today was the most
important uh element
of analysis despite this
when you publish on alienation today and
when you put
actually the word alienation in the
title i notice that there is
an incredible interest even
more than usual and there are
many books many articles
published on alienation or on fetishism
so in this rediscovery of marx in this
marx revival i see that there is a lot
about alienation
and about fetishism and let's try to
discuss together
please help me i need your help why this
is possible
i have an an answer i will try to
provide
[Music]
my idea my opinion and then we'll see
what you two believe and then there will
be question criticism
so even though alienation for us
is a classic in the marxist thoughts
and if we look at the topics alienation
is perhaps one of the top
five topics like marx and alienation is
as important as
marx and communism and marx and critical
political economy
i want to say that this phenomenon is
something
very very recent and here i'm talking
to the students who are listening i
would be a little bit
uh boring for those who are big marx
excerpt
experts but i would like to spend a
couple of minutes discussing this with
students i lost
paul north for the moment but he's back
now okay
so why alienation is something new
alienation is something new because
the text which is not a book but
it's a very very first stage manuscript
that marx wrote for himself
the famous economical philosophical
manuscript of 1844
which is to complete what i was saying
before
the most important texts in terms of
philosophy so what is read about marx in
the department of philosophy and not
only there
all over the world one of the most sold
book
in philosophy in the 20th century this
text was written by marx in 1844
but was actually published in 1932
and the fortune of the concept of
alienation
is actually very much related to this
text on marx
because when this book was published in
1932 now everybody will say oh it was
the beginning of the nation the world no
not at all
one year after hitler took you know
germany and they were trying to burn
mark's manuscript
and the manuscript of marx were sent
to london and then denmark and then they
ended the majority of them in amsterdam
in the beautiful institute for
international institute for social
history but before the end of world war
ii so end of the 40s
second part of the 40s beginning of the
50s
this text the economical philosophical
manuscript of 1844
was not known was unknown right
so the concept of alienation starts to
have
this important place in the tradition of
marxism
only after the publication of this text
and also the question of fetishism to go
back to capital
because there is this famous uh section
that i will try to discuss
later when we approach the fourth point
of our conversation today but if you
look at the debate
in the second international in the third
international if you look at the books
article written by
kowski lenin bernstein labriola
sorel they didn't write about alienation
about
fetishism even though fetishism was
published and was there
since 1867 or actually paul reiter since
1872
because it only when marx did that new
german edition that
fetishism appears in a better way
so i'm also asking questions to my
discussions so alienation is
a relevant place today because it is
still um considered one of the main
topics for marx
this tradition started you know in the
early 50s like 70 years ago
and i will say most importantly than
this because
we never lived in such an alienated
society like today
that's the most important answer for me
like a researcher that is not
only close in this room office in the
university
so i believe that marx is relevant today
of course many of his analysis must be
updated must be changed there were many
mistakes many limits problems like every
other thinkers
but capitalism today
is so spread so much globally in every
region of the world
and is so present in every aspect
of our life that i cannot think about
you know another concept
that is
as relevant as this one that can be used
as this one
the question and i stop here and i pass
the microphone to you the question is to
understand
what marks really meant for ali nation
right because there are many different
ideas many different approaches and i
don't know if you want to go there now
or if you want to wait a little bit more
so let's see what my
discussion and those things
well i think you do a a very nice job of
framing the
some some of these questions i mean you
did a nice job here but also in the
article that that was circulated and
uh there is a long-running debate about
the relationship between marx's early
views
on on alienation alienation as it's
framed in the
uh manuscripts that you were just
talking about and
the way of talking about
what is in effect alienation that marx
has in
in capital and uh i was excited i read
your article really just
before uh we we started
uh this event and so i'm i'm actively
still processing it but
uh i was i was excited to to see how you
frame the fetishism section of capital
in the context of this discussion
of alienation and this very artful
genealogy of different ways that
alienation
has been has been
[Music]
picked up on uh reworked
um in the various traditions of
of marxist theorizing and i think that
with
with uh fetishism um the appeal of that
section i mean it has multiple
levels of appeal uh
one is that it's been influential in a
certain kind of cultural theory that
remains influential and people who come
to marx from
that side of things or with those
affinities we'll we'll feel drawn to it
but i think that
as capitalism expands becomes more
complex
uh i think there's a a more
pressing need or a more urgent
desire to to work through its
mystifications and
this is as for me at least
uh the most rhetorically powerful uh
attempt in capital to formulate the
the mystifications of capital how
capital as a system
throws off false appearances and
misleads people
and the role that these mystifications
play um in its
in its ability to to dominate them
that was more a comment than like a
question exactly
um but uh you know i actually i like
this very much because this is
completing what i was trying to to say
before
and i have also prepared something that
unless
you and paul north disagree with me um
soon i'm going to share the the
powerpoint a little bit
a little powerpoint that i prepared so
that the students who are
following are not scared about this
you know big concept and definition that
we provide but perhaps they can
read so i have selected paul a couple of
definitions from the article that you
just mentioned and then
we might want to go back on this on this
topic
later but what you told me is very
useful for me because it helps me
to move forward in this discussion about
what kind of alienation are we reading
so that
conception of fetishism it was so
powerful
and it was already there from the very
beginning but
a right as you said but arrives to the
attention
of um you know
activists no not only scholars but
activists
um only after there is this
big um interest that is at the beginning
a philosophical
interest i would say for uh for
alienation i don't know if paul north
disagree with me let's see what what he
was saying
later but in the 50s
in this tradition of french
existentialism for example
or all this philosopher or all these
readers coming from different
political and cultural traditions let's
think for example about
jesuits in in france and later also in
in latin america with liberation
theology
significant uh social movements and um
uh political ideologies the school of
thoughts i don't know
how you want to define this um they
are actually making a choice and the
choice
that they are making is that they are
reading a particular marks
and this marks is the so-called
young marx which i believe is one of the
biggest inventions in the history of
marx's studies again another provocation
for my
for my discussions so
i never said marx would have done this
marx would have said that
marx would have voted for this party etc
etc
but one things that recently i allow
myself to say
and believe me is the only one is that i
am strongly convinced that marx will be
shocked if he would see how much
attention the humanity has given
to this manuscript that he wrote when he
was only 25
26 years old this beautiful wonderful
manuscript
i want to say that i wrote my
dissertation on the economic
philosophical manuscript of 1844
i love them i don't believe to them who
say this
not marx okay but
we cannot uh um
overestimate the importance of this
manuscript
and do not study what just paul
reiter said you know fetishes mean
capital and also
all the making of the concept of
alienation and
fetishism and rarification as i will
show later by using the terminology of
lucas
that started in 1857 with the grundrisse
i prepared something so i don't want to
intervene on this point now
but what i want to say is that
unfortunately and i will use this uh
word in this big debate about alienation
and
about marx capital was
lost in many countries and in many
political translations
and there was a very significant portion
portion of readers of interpreters of
marx
who decided that the economical
manuscript of 1844
was the most relevant place
i believe that this is wrong because
this was the idea that capital belonged
to soviet union
and that dogmatic economic economicistic
reading of capital was the correct
reading of capital
but i just want to say that capital was
mark's life
because marx what capital wrote capital
from 1857 from the introduction that he
wrote
in july of 57 exactly at the same time
that the crisis started
the crisis that i mentioned before in
new york because he said
angus i no longer have time to play the
revolution is coming now
and i must have my book out as always he
was wrong the revolution didn't come
but at least this was the first push to
have
the first draft of capital the grundris
you know this uh
eight notebooks uh that he wrote in only
uh um six months and then this draft of
capital they just
ended in 1881 at the very end when marx
was
extremely tired extremely old but i have
no time to talk about this
unless you don't ask me to do it but i
want to go back on this division on this
distinction
between the early writings and capital
and
this was around the concept of
alienation so the concept of alienation
was the key concept
in this division of schools of
interpretation
many people they belong to different
parties different cultures different
traditions different countries different
fields
they decided that the economical
philosophical manuscript of 1844
was the most important text ever written
by marx
and that the conception of alienation
that was there
was the most relevant one i believe that
this interpretation as i just said
is wrong but also the second party
there is the party of ultraser that is
the party of
the institute in moscow and many other
people
that were more or less closer
to the dogmatic tradition of marxism
they refused the marks of 1844
and they even said that dead marx was
not marxism and that actually marxism
started in 1845 with the german ideology
with the book and now we know as i just
said they did not exist
so there is a problem also in this other
reading the reading of the
epistemological break right if you want
to use a very famous expression
and then in my division of these three
families of these three categories
there is a third one which is the party
of the continuity
between the early writings and capital
and this is where i will collocate
myself
i will go there if i have to decide in
which of these three houses
i am going to live but in this
party of the continuity i have many
problems with actually the majority of
scholars who belong to this
interpretation
because i strongly believe that there is
a huge
difference between the analysis of 1844
and the analysis that started with the
ground resistance the analysis of
alienation
the analysis of alienation that you read
in the grundrisa that you read in the
theory of surplus values in many other
manuscripts preparatory manuscript of
capital that today we can read thanks to
the mega
and then this question of fetishism that
was published in capital
well this is a much stronger analysis
there is a much stronger understanding
of the social economical
issues in the society and i'm done paul
i see that you want to intervene and
there is also
political there is also political
experience that was done by marx so marx
is not only
learning from these books but he's also
learning from this eight years that he's
been in the international
and he learned many things so when he's
posing this question to himself these
are also questions that are related to
the organization of the society and
that's why i've decided
to dedicate the last part of this
contribution
to the question of the alienation and
communism
because i believe that there is a strong
connection between this free society the
concerns of this free society
and mark's ideas of post-capitalism
it's terrific i feel like we're getting
a view of this one figure
alienation and how the streams of marx's
own development and reception and
the reinvestment in marx form
whirlpools around this term i i'm a kind
of cut to the chase kind of person
sometimes
and i wonder if um we can say a little
more what was alienation
in the manuscripts what was alienation
in capital
why do you think those other terms like
fetish or
objectification reification are
translations of it or
take up some of its work maybe this is
one of the parts of your presentation
which
yes and as i said before to paul
uh writer i would just like to share
if you agree because i believe it's it's
better for
the students who are listening unless
you tell me that i
better read a couple of definitions but
let's see if this works and i'm going to
share my uh screen here
so hopefully you can you can see it
can you confirm
and we say very well thanks so i will go
back to
this question uh later uh so to
something that is related to
ali initially marks where because i said
that
is not only or merely or the most
important in 1844 so i would like to
discuss with you
where we see the alienation but let's go
to this question of the terminology
it is very complicated because if we go
into the
um question of um
i'm just seeing a paul north now because
i
have to read from the from my uh um
powerpoint but if we go into this um
analysis you know the etymology of the
word alienation for late in exeter
or the war that alienation was used i
don't know in the
traditional political economy like
selling said this would take a lot of
time
right so i'm not going to do this but i
will i wanted to say something about
hegel because hegel is of course very
relevant for marx in particular not only
for this marx of 1844
so the students who are listening to us
and now
they are reading this they see that i
am referencing to the phenomenology of
the spirit
which eagle published in 1807 wrote in
1807.
if you want to wrote if you want to know
what is the phenomenology of spirit for
marx
you have to know two things number one
is something very wonderful and
fascinating and marx had such a big
respect for this work but number two
mark said many times in a couple of
letters this is worse than going to the
dentist
okay something like this if you want to
read it if you want to understand
it's extremely difficult so in this book
you find
this terminology and toys room which is
literally
self-externalization or actually
renunciation
and and fremdom estrangement and
eagle is talking about the spirit
becoming older than itself
in the realm of objectivity i am
actually more familiar with the debate
about
how to translate alienation in italian
spanish etc and my english not only my
thick accent is not the best but um
we will discuss later and i will be
learn from
from paul rater and we will
i mean you decide if we want to discuss
this more
what is important for marx is the
category of
alienated labor okay that is end frame
that they are by
which is what you find more often in the
epm
of 1844 so marx is here
um expanding the problematic of
alienation okay so the problematic
validation is not only related to
philosophy to religion when i say
religion you have to consider that marx
was part of this
group the left age alien and they were
trying to criticize
hegel and there is this famous
philosopher ludwig feuerbach he's
writing about
religion so this is the beginning of the
tradition of materialism but what is
beautiful really unique wonderful about
this manuscript
um is the fact that there is a mix
of philosophy and economics sometimes uh
paul north i can only see you but
raymond ron the conservative
french sociologist he was making fun of
all this um
leftists in the 60s in paris reading the
epm of 1844 there are very brilliant
quotations
and you know this is the kind of text it
was said
that you use when you want to impress
you know your boyfriend your girlfriend
when you want to play the part of the
intellectual
right full of this wonderful quotation
hegel's meat etc
it is when max actually fall in love
with political economy because marx read
the political economist
in october 1843 for the first time and
by the way thanks to
engels because it was english who was
before marx traveling to england looking
at contradiction of capitalism
and then reading the classics
in any case alienation is presented as
the phenomenon through which
the labor product confront labor and
here is the quotation as something
alien as a power independent of the
producer from the producer
so for marx alienation and torso of the
worker
in his product means not only that his
labor becomes an object
an external existence but they did exist
outside him independently and something
alien to him and that he becomes a power
and is on confronting him it means that
the life which he had comfort on the
object confronts
him her as something hostile and
alien i don't want to make this
extremely boring okay but there are four
ways in which
marx defines alienation in the economic
philosophical manuscript
and there is a lot of attention that has
been paid
to this question of um
uh immaterial alienation so
not only alienation is the process in
the factory of the workers etc but also
that you are alienated from your species
being
right from other humans there is
in my opinion too much of this
in many philosophical and interpretation
in psychology we can discuss about this
later if you want
or when we open the floor two questions
as i was saying before
alienation in the ground is an order
preparatory manuscript i cannot do
quotations here because it will be too
long
but i would like to take two more
minutes to show you
where i find many alienation in marks
so here is enriched by a greater
understanding of economic categories
because marx had just started marx was
not even reading ricardo's myth
in english since we are discussing
translation a lot here he was reading
them
through french translation and he goes
back to them in english only later
in the 50s when it's doing the famous
londoner
notebooks and there is also a more
rigorous social analysis i was saying
before perhaps i would say
social and also political analysis
so um this book written by lukas history
and class consciousness
was very important as was very relevant
another book written by rubin
about fetishism this um political
economist
because these two scholars even do
the mode right of alienation
hadn't started yet this big mod that i
try to discuss at the beginning with
paul north when we say that the 60s and
the 70s
riding of variation was almost a must
if you were in the department of
philosophy or political science
without this georgi lucas in 1923
he introduced another term which is very
relevant for marxist tradition the term
of
reification
is the thing right so this is the term
to describe the phenomenon
whereby labor activities confront human
beings as something objective and
independent
dominating them through external
autonomous law
this is interesting this is uh
you know remarkable but something that
many
people don't know is that lukaku was
actually
used later by those scholars
and professors intellectuals that i
mentioned before
those who believe that alienation in
1844 is the most
relevant conception of alienation made
by marx
it was used by them because in this book
written in 1923
lucas is still sharing the idea of hegel
that every objectification has
alienation it means that every society
it doesn't matter if there is a model
production that is a capitalist model
production or is a collective
socialist model production you will have
alienation there so lucas is very angry
where they are translating this book
in the 60s in french and is also writing
a special new preface for
history and class consciousness and he's
saying i was
too hegelian at the time now i change my
position
we can go back to this later and also i
want to dedicate one minute to this
question of
the alienation in so-called actually
existing socialism
in the final part of my presentation
here is what the
paul writer told us before
so the fetishism of commodity and
secrets this is the this section
in volume one of capital where max
showed that in capitalist society people
are dominated by the product they have
created
here the relation among them appear not
as direct social relation
between person social sorry social
relation between person but rather as
material relation between person and
social relation between things
so fetishism is the name given to the
attribution to things commodities of
what
are in fact social relations
so let's say that there is an inversion
process that affect
people in the capitalist system and this
is similar to the phenomenon
of religious fetishism there is a normal
social relation and they are replaced by
relation between
things this is what marx wants to say
here
not opening the big discussion about
fetishism in religion and the
contribution of marcel moss in 1907
after you know criticizing what debros
wrote about fetishes
which is which was a book that max read
when he was very very young at the time
of the university
i'm scared can i ask you a question in
the middle
yes you can i just want to say that i'm
skipping this part
but this is the famous definition that
uh
paul was you know rephrasing in a very
brilliant way before and that
we know so now i stop sharing my scream
and uh i'm back please confirm that you
can see me
we see you thank you this is a quick
question but
it's really what's most on my mind
i feel like the danger of the word
alienation
in existentialism in other discourses
is that it be taken as a psychological
state a mood an affect
with which to see the world or live your
life that colors the way things are
it seems to me that um you're saying as
you line it up with fetishism and
objectification that it isn't a mood
that it isn't something an individual
feels
and in a sense this is what hegel said
it's a part of a process
of constructing the self in which the
self
confirms that there's something other
than it by separating itself from itself
but what do you think the the
non-psychological reading
of alienation is for marx
in capital where does it hit us
is it a matter of power and control is
it
are we supposed to think about how we
react to a certain situation or is it a
structural issue
thanks uh any uh remarks
question or criticism from paul uh
writer or can i
go ahead with this one and then there is
more later
my dogs are barking right now so i'm
going to leave it at that
thanks it was nice um
[Music]
yes there is
a period in which we had something that
might be called the sort of
irresistible fascination of the theory
of alienation
it was the age of alienation to cool
right there was
a real vogue and alienation
just to um read a quotation from
this article that i shared with you from
various political background
and academic disciplines they identified
um alienation the causes of alienation
as
commodification over-specialization
anomie
bureaucratization conformism consumerism
loss of the sense of self-aimed new
technologies
personal isolation apathy
social or ethnical imagination
environmental pollution
so really this world alienation didn't
mean
anything in the end and
i also want to add one more point before
trying to answer to the very
short but extremely difficult uh
question
that paul made that also in sociology
alienation completely changed the
meaning
perhaps not in the sense of looking at
the individual but
in the sense that alienation became
something positive
okay so for marx alienation is clear is
always
a negative phenomenon that we have to
try to
fight okay not overcome
forever with just a revolution i will go
back to this point later
but trying to make it smaller less and
max is also suggesting
something at least i will try to provide
some ideas
in the final part of the talk in
sociology in the country in north
america and mainstream sociology
they treated alienation as a positive
things
and the question of how you look at this
concept
this is completely different for marx it
is always the question
of the individual i'm saying this not
because i'm trying to borrow time from
the question of paul but because
actually i'm trying to answer to this
question
in a perhaps
difficult way so the individual is the
center
for me means that the individual must
conform must change so
it is not the question of social
relations of the society
that must change it is a question of
adaptation of the individual
it is a question that you are not
looking for
solution um general changes
but you're looking for solution of the
individual of their capacity to adjust
their capacity to accept the existing
order
and you know the practice of our society
now why marx is writing about this
and what is the understanding of marx
what is the
the the meaning of what he's doing
well first of all i would say that in
capital he's doing this because
he wants to understand the society
so this concept is useful for us
uh like many other concepts that you
will um
discuss in this extremely brilliant and
wonderful seminar that you organize
like for example the question of money
right that
it's so relevant for our life but it's
so difficult to define
and to understand and this one too
how is it possible that our relations
is not a direct relation but actually we
interact with each other through these
commodities through these things
so max is trying to understand the
society
is trying to describe the society and
he's also using
this religious
as he wrote here i call this
fetishism which attach itself to the
product of labor
as soon as they are produced as
commodity
and is therefore inseparable from the
production of commodities so
uh it is not um
here it is quotation and you know in
order to find an analogy we must take
flight into the misty realm of religion
and this is what i wanted to mention
before
but there is one point that is very
relevant for me
and here you have a very political
reading of
mass conception of alienation i don't
know if you agree with this
but the difference between this
pages of marx when he wrote
for himself as i will tell you later or
where he wrote
uh for an audience because he wanted to
publish because he published
the book that he was writing like in the
case of capital grundris say the
manuscript that he wrote for himself
well i read in this
pages a theory that is a theory to
understand the society
but also a theory to shake the society
to
change the society so not only
a coherent theoretic theoretical basis
for the understanding capitalism and
alienation
but also an anti-capitalist ideological
platform like when i write in this
article
um alienation left the books of the
philosopher relation is no longer a
debate
even too brilliant and fascinating that
this
young uh ye progressive left again and
we're having in berlin
after angel hegel died
so it's not something that takes place
only in
the lecture hall of university but it's
something that
must go to the streets must go to social
movements to trade unions to political
parties
and in my opinion this is also why this
concept had such a strong
fortune at least in i always think with
my european eyes right i see
my european eyes in the 60s in the 70s
because there was
a fantastic political and social
movement that exploded in those years
and this books of marx even though they
were written in such a difficult and
complicated way
paul writer is lucky because he's
re-translating capital volume one and
not the grundrus
that would be perhaps even more
complicated i don't know i'm just also
joking
but even though grundris is so difficult
they could
see that their that interpretation of
marks those ideas on marks are also
something that
belong to their life are useful for
their life and this is why they were so
um used and you know circulated the
words for many decades
that's terrific i think now we've set
the stage
for de-alienation and
hopefully what comes after it or what
might come after it
communism would you like to
jump to that part
yes can i be
[Music]
so impolite to take one more minute and
to go back to something
in my powerpoint that i think is
useful for
the youngest
[Music]
can you see my powerpoint here thanks
to the students who are here um
this is something that i've been editing
it's uh anthology
um i don't want to do advertisement but
um it's a book that will come out
in december and i would like to tell you
the work that i've done in putting
together this ontology
um so ali initially marks where
okay this is my question i wanted to
re-establish the relevance of
economic writings and of this
better major understanding of capitalism
i don't like to use
young nature this world but you know at
least we understand each other by
saving time uh i believe that we
must concentrate our attention when we
talk about alienation in marx on the
most
relevant pages of mark's later economic
writing so
not only the economic of philosophical
writings
of 1844 and
i had to divide the book in three parts
for editorial reasons
this is my research that i want to share
with you
uh opal is not too boring but i want to
try to explain this
so when we look at this early
philosophical writings or to
you know what max wrote in the 50s right
um there is not very much about
alienation
after the um 1844 so this is not on
james meal they were written at the same
time
of the economic philosophical manuscript
for me actually they
belong to the economic philosophical
manuscript because marx is just writing
these things for himself
and there is a lot of about alienation
that is writing because he is
stimulated by the smoke elements of
political economy
after this after this big
analysis and putting together a
philosophy
with political economy
the concept disappears there are just
few references
in the holy family the german ideology
but
actually this is something that is
very um small and marx is sorry not very
small
it's something that marx is very
critical of this
it's very critical because uh marx
is now speaking to an audience that is
no longer the audience of this
brilliant but very few uh philosophers
in berlin now marx is
in the political fight he is an activist
in paris he was
exposed from france from belgium then he
goes back to france in 1848
who will talk to workers and who will
tell them
you are alienated you are in strange
you are reificated there is a fetishism
even though marx didn't know
didn't use this expression at the time
with relation to political economy
look what happened here so when marx
is starting to write capital
the first so-called draft of capital de
grundris
the appliance of the critical political
economy i found
11 000 words so i found a lot
because this is what marx is writing
for himself so when we talk about marks
i'm sorry that you cannot see me paul
you tell me if i have to
put the powerpoint down or if more
useful to
show you this but i will try to stop
share and then i will come back so you
can see me
it is very relevant for us to understand
that there is a difference between
what marx wrote to publish capital and
then there is the problem of what marx
wanted to change
because marks change capital volume one
in a couple of occasions and you would
have done even more
so not only you have to know what is the
difference between what max wrote
a very few uh project
compared to the many projects that he
had were completed my marks and they
were published i'm exaggerating a little
bit but you know we can count them
then there are the manuscripts that marx
wrote for himself
like for example the grundris
self-clarification
self-esteem or preparatory writings that
marx is drafting and no
is not satisfied and move forward and
forward then there is
journalism then there is the
correspondence with all the people which
was essential for the um you know
political propaganda and then the very
relevant
uh manuscript notebooks in which marx
was studying and was taking notes
so when max is writing the second
category of
writings that i just mentioned now the
manuscript preparatory manuscript
you will find a lot this text number
eight
this is called the ur text so this is
the preparatory text
for the first book of political economy
that marx published in 1859
contribution to the critical political
economy so you see that there is
not very much there but look marx is
writing about
alienation extensively not only in the
grundris
but also in a draft that
is um only partially translated into
english that in the mega is called
manuscript 1861 1863 the mega is the
german edition historical critical
edition and then in the tier of surprise
value that marx wrote between
62 and 63 there is a lot so
i learn a lot when i read this texas
i understand alienation but actually
more than understanding alienation i
understand capitalism
much better than when i read the text of
1844
and then the final part here capital
you know this is really when marx is
writing capital so these are not
manuscript
written for himself this is uh
very important for us the so-called
unpublished chapter six
marx is returning on this question with
very brilliant beautiful way
these are all the places where you find
the
ideas that capital is vampire and is
taking the blood of the
living labor etc and then this is what
paul writer mentioned at the beginning
the
famous section of volume 1
and there is also chapter capital volume
3 okay so there is a lot of capital that
is a lot of alienation that you find
and and the part that you find in the
early writings
is a very minoritarian and perhaps not
even the most
important one
thank you marcelo this is such a gift to
have
all of this laid out for us i feel like
we should open up to
everyone's questions they've been
thinking this through with you
very soon i'm not sure if you want to
give an abbreviated
version of the how to de-alienate and
is this a how-to do we have a recipe for
de-alienating
i would like to leave the recipe for the
end in case somebody is asking for a
recipe let's see let's see what happens
right because
it's possible the discussion will go
there but um
that's great ask your boy if it's
possible that i
answer two two three question together
not one by one
so we give more chances to answer two
more questions i might be able to
combine them if
if i can okay
thank you very much this would be a
moment in which there would be
thunderous applause if we were in a
fleshy setting
so we can all thank you for this it
represents
many years of work and a a couple of
decades of
working through marks and you said that
the
the volume on alienation this anthology
is going to be out in december
yes it's going to be published on
december the 8th by december 8th
excellent
well congratulations
what i'd like to do is ask
for questions from the students in the
seminar this is not
a two-tiered system but they're
young and they're just working through
marks so i want to give them
kind of first opportunity to articulate
their questions and then we will turn to
anybody and everybody who's here who has
questions so if the students would put
their questions
in the chat then we will try
to unmute the asker
and have them ask their question and
we'll do a couple of them
as marcelo asks
don't make me take away from your grade
students if you don't ask
questions that's all right i'm not going
to do that
maybe it will take some time for them to
uh
i see there are many many questions here
many
interventions but
we are starting with the student as you
say oh let's start with ali
okay um audrey if you're there
would you unmute ali
yep she they are muted hi
uh thank you very much for your uh for
your lecture i think it was really
insightful
my question refers to the initial
remarks that you had about the revival
of marxist reading
following the 2008 crisis and especially
the political revival in
latin america i wonder what you make of
the revival in
trotsky's mobilization as well
significantly in argentina
do you think it's a reaction to the
failed bolshevik cause or is it a sign
of
certain kind of yearning for an
internationalist approach
a symptom of a methodological vacuum
that we face right now
or more as a general question can
revolution be alienated on its
ideological grounds
as well just like the labor
i don't know if it was if that was clear
but
yeah can pen revolution be alienated
right
yes or as the revolution
and in its imagined forms
muted maybe we'll take a couple of the
other questions that are in here
can we go back to liz
and would someone unmute her and ask her
to read her question
this is complicated to do but i prefer
to hear everyone's voice or see their
face when they're asking i think that's
um can you guys hear me yes
okay so i actually made a comment which
um anna questioned so the question was
marcelo are you saying
that the concept of alienation as it
appeared in the 1844 manuscripts that it
kind of fractured into multiple
different
more precise concepts like mystification
or commodity fetishism is that is that
kind of your argument about what happens
to alienation
um as it goes on
you and the remark and also can you
repeat your name please
uh my name is liz kinnaman liz right liz
liz okay let's go from there to one more
um we're already moved out of the realm
of the students who obviously all fail
and but that's okay you're thinking
people the students in this course are
really
putting their best brain cells into this
so
it is true that it takes some time could
we
open up the voice and picture of baruch
jimenez contreras who has
comments and questions
hi i am interesting in the concept of
alienation and i
have a little paper in a color
document about it and i identify that
before the manuscript of
1844 there are another perspective of
alienation in
economic history of ideas
and specifically in adam's meet
what why do you think that mark does not
refer to these discoveries in his work
it's it's all thank you
arcelor i had problem in understanding
would you be so kind to repeat
please
[Music]
okay marcelo this is three do you want
to go ahead and respond
uh i'll take one more if you can but if
there are another question i wonder
i'm ready to ask you have a a student
showing up can we unmute laurence liu
please um
yeah sorry i'm in the midst of an eating
orange
um i yeah i was really surprised by
um your comments at the beginning when
you were discussing like the sort of
different national revivals of mark's
readings
and you said that sort of chinese
students ended up
um and by that i mean students in china
ended up focusing on certain issues and
not others and it made me think of
um the sort of communist party's push
right now for what they call
like socialism with chinese
characteristics and
the sort of increasing pressure that you
know um
that's being reported on on academics to
sort of show up
china's sort of brand of development
like state and private development right
um and sort of an emergence of a new
intellectual class of like
chinese political theorists who are
trying to like justify
like xi jinping's rule um and
so i was just wondering how you see a
relationship between chinese politics
today and the sort of
new the new sorts of readings of remarks
that are coming out
okay marcelo you're on you know the name
of the last
student lawrence right lawrence here
was nice to see lawrence because i can
see also his um
his face um so there are four questions
and um as i suspected and as i said to
paul north and paul writer there is a
lot of interest for the marx revival
so i'm happy to to hear about this
i will start from this um
[Music]
two questions the last lawrence and the
first ali because in my opinion they are
connected so lawrence
i have as i'm sure that you have
understood from my presentation uh i
don't share
this um reading of marx you know the
marxist leninist
tradition breeznet in soviet union
imaging
china today so i'm not saying
that
you know like some other scholars that
you know
mark's ideas are reviving in china etc
what i was trying to say is that i
was glad to see and i look at this
phenomenon with a lot of interest that
in some of the main universities that i
visited
the university of nanjing where i worked
as a visiting professor
fudan university in shanghai even in
beijing even though i'm
a little bit more complicated i saw many
people
engaged in translating and bringing
new readings only of marx
marx's tradition and also you know
philosophy for example other authors
into chinese and what i
said perhaps i was talking too fast or
with my poor english
that i was looking at this in a positive
way
like i was looking at this as the
possibility to
interact with a new generation of
students of scholars also trying to
listen
what they do it took me some time but i
found
very interesting partners and now
they're writing articles and books and
chapters that i
have to publish or include in my edited
volumes or in the journal i collaborate
with or in my series
i think this is very good so i
went to dead university and nanjing and
i saw for example that they have an
institute where they
translate uh friedrich james on right
and i was surprised there is a lot of
interest for that recently there were
some problems because also some of these
altars that are translated
sometimes they sign petition against
you know oppressive political decision
of the regime and that's why
they were also cuts in the in the last
year and a half two years but i was just
mentioning the fact that
it is good that this is possible now
and i see that the students in china are
also very
hungry thirsty they want to read they
want to learn
they want to interact so this is good
to ali i want to talk about argentina
and my experiences in argentina
they were two conferences
in 2018 in in argentina
one was the bicentenary of mark so they
were
doing this kind of big conference and
they were able to get there was a very
conservative government at the time one
of the most
conservative in in south america
they got in the end the the big um
the the the biggest hole the biggest
venue which was
the the uh the the the museum the old of
the library or the museum i don't
remember the name now
and they were expecting a very big
success they were expecting
500 people there when the organizer
you know were working that morning and
they came out from the subway and look
at the number of people who were in line
they could not believe it there were
thousands of people
and most of them were young people
many young women many young students
they were there because they wanted to
learn about marx and they didn't even
have
an impressive international program with
big name like nancy fraser david rv they
were just there because of marx they
were just there because it was a
curiosity of marx
myself i went to argentina the same year
for an event and paul you allow me if i
can be a little bit biographical and
make a little bit lighter at this point
of the conversation
the same here there was the clock so
they had the conference claxo is the
organization for social science in the
latin america and the caribbean and it's
about
many things many topics
there are generally 40 000 people who
attend this event
just coming from outside the organizing
country
i was one of the guests in the
lecture about marx there were two other
guests one is
chintzya ruzza that you are inviting
here in a few weeks
and the other one is a swedish
professor who was a sociologist
at cambridge and his name is goran
telborn
and the three of us were actually
impressed
because we were hostages in a very big
room
which was packed like in a way that i've
never seen before
and i was surprised to see that that
room was for marx it was not from
diego perotti one of my favorite
argentinian actors who was giving
a presentation in the room after so i
went to the other presentation but they
realized that marx was the place with
more people waiting on the line outside
so this is the kind of enthusiasm that
marx is creating
in some parts of the world there are
parts of the world where you cannot
mention the name of marx and one of the
geographical areas where there are more
problems is for example
eastern europe because they associate
marx
to that kind of communism okay so you
will not see there like for example
marx has not been read in north korea
for at least the last 30 years by
anybody even though they say
marxism is what you see in north korea
so the party in argentina which is a
party that i know
very well comes from this trotsky's
tradition
was the organization that existed in
argentina
was the most structured one and
they were very successful in responding
to this demand
so you know they entered in parliament
they elected the
many members of parliament they are
active they give a good contribution
and if i may say one more things the
most beautiful thing that i've seen in
argentina is this uh
social movement about the question of
feminism this
new generation of activism and they are
also trying to interrogate marx
i think that mars would love to learn a
lot from them if he was alive
but that kind of approach that they have
they kind of look at the society i found
it very close
to many things that marx wrote i see
that paul wants to intervene
no just a small comment i worry that
with so many people going to conferences
on marxism's works that they'll miss the
revolution if it actually happens
you have a couple more there and we have
two more i'm just conscious of people's
time
so you have two more questions to
respond to maybe and then we'll take
two more that are in the chat
that's a possibility in any case i am
very happy to stay here for
all the questions and to respond to all
the students but i want to force
my chair to be there for the end of the
night so you decide
baruch marx didn't analyze
smith because as i mentioned at the
beginning
and surely i was not clear the concept
of alienation that you seems
meet the problematic that you see in the
wealth of nation
is very different from the way marx is
using
that word so the word alienation is
something that is more about
selling if i understand your question
correctly
why marx is using alienation
as one of the main category in order to
explain
to workers because capital was written
for workers
how crazy our society is how
inverted are our relations our social
relations
in capitalist mode of production and at
least
the last question the second um
it was a very good one yes i think
this is the most difficult question so
far even more than one that paul
asked me at the beginning and i don't
have enough time
to discuss this but liz is asking are
you saying that what we read in 1844
is fractured in more concept later
well i would say that what
that definition of alienation is
illustrating is illustrating for the
point of view of
human relations the worker in the
factory the worker
with the other worker the worker within
self
or in the relationship with the object
in the division of labor
then there is a concept of alienation
which is what we discussed
before um thanks to what uh polar
writer said fetishism that is a concept
that is alienation in relation to the
commodity
okay so i don't have time to say exactly
fracture at each other but
they are different angles one is the
angles
of the human relation and the other one
is the angle of the commodity
then there is the big question of the
society and perhaps if i have time i
will go back to something that i
prepared but
let's see what are the other questions
and where we are going
terrific i'm going to there's
two that seem to lead from one to the
other so i'm going to
read for felix
whose microphone is not working his
question in the chat the commodity
fetishism is generally seen as a
defining characteristic
of the capitalist mode of production
however marx's discussion of the
commodity fetishism and capital
precedes his shift from exchange to
production and the introduction of the
class relation between capital and labor
what do you make of the argument of
george henderson and others
that the commodity fetishism is
consequently applicable beyond
capitalism due to its basis in exchange
and not production a technical question
but and then if you want to uh alexander
codetronis pardon my horrible
pronunciation
um asks does marx see de-alienation as
something that can be total
is it a constant process and that gives
you a chance to tell us what
what you think that is yeah uh
i would like to share my email address i
don't know if it
appeared on the on the
um the presentation of the lecture in
any case it's my website is my name and
my surname marcelomusto.org
and people students can write me
hopefully i'm not going to get 15 20
emails but
i would be very happy to discuss this
uh question that felix is asking me
paul help me i don't know how i can do
this without
you know taking 10-15 minutes and saying
goodbye to the end of the
of the conversation so i hope that felix
is
not um angry at me if i
will be in touch with him separately
because this is related to
you know very specific things an
interpretation an organ
an author and uh i might also provide a
couple of readings
and this along that line
do you have just a quick answer to the
question um is there non-alienated
labor or is there non-alienated
non-alienated sociality
uh that's you know one of the most
interesting point for me and i will try
to
argue uh to answer to this one in
connection with
um the other question just please paul s
help me your question is
how much does the alienated really on
fantasies on subjectivity wholeness that
one
that's one of them yes yeah and then
there's um alexander's
alex because i see alexander there
um
[Music]
okay alexander does mark see the
alienation as something that can be
total or the alienation of the custom
process
good so i will try to discuss these
things there is um
a very nice quotation from um
[Music]
and he's talking about the fact that at
some point
um in soviet union
they did not want to hear the question
alienation
they did not want to discuss alienation
because
they were responding simply like we have
socialism
therefore we no longer have alienation
so
alienation could and must no longer be
an
issue for them i had the same kind of
answer
in uh in china and i had a couple of uh
brilliant professors were hosting me
the conversation went to uh social work
and the making of this new department of
social work by the way
very mainstream and american approach to
social work
and there is nothing of political in
their social workers
work in brazil is one of the most
progressive disciplines
and it was also essential the
contribution that they had
in uh formating people militant
activists against the
dictatorship so they said why do you
want social work we have socialism
right so there was this idea that
socialism is
the end of the contradiction you find
this kind of approaches
also in
authors from from europe so called
western authors for example
lucian goldman jose goldman wrote about
this
and he said that it is possible to
overcome alienation
definitely overcome alienation in the
social economic condition of the time
and is actually writing that alienation
i'm reading the quotation here from his
dialectical research 1959 very important
moment for the alienation debate
is in fact a phenomenon closely bound up
with the absence of planning
and with production for the market he
said that soviet socialism
in the east and kenzian policies in the
west
were resulting in the first case
elimination of reification and in the
second
case in a progressive weakening of
alienation
well i believe that history has
demonstrated the faultiness
of these predictions right and this is
not the position of marx even though
marx has been read and described by this
you know teleology and this position end
of history etc
which is something that you find in marx
there are three four passages in which
is writing in that way
but um sometimes these are political
passages so you have to be careful what
text are you reading
sometimes is also uh the fact that you
know marx wrote
thousands of pages and so you can find
many things sometimes because marx was
wrong right so there are different
answers and options to this but his
ideas
is not that you do the revolution you
put a red star at the top of
building and there is no longer
alienation in that society
and actually these actually existing
uh socialism society they proved to go
in the opposite direction like for
example when the workers in
berlin in the so-called east berlin
they were struggling against one of the
first measures that were taken by the
government
which was not the reduction of the
working day but it was the increase
of the working day so you find this kind
of things
i would like to share once again the
power point if i'm allowed
and i would like to say
what marx wrote about this
i don't know if at some point we can
make this uh
powerpoint uh available um
[Music]
you can read this one so i believe that
the question of
the alienation the writing of alienation
are useful
for the research that you know the um
that marx did on communist society the
description of post-capitalist society
and i had prepared
this question that are essential
question for marx i can only list them
paul don't be worried
just 30 more seconds very quickly the
essential topic for marx
you know a d-alienated society a
communist society
as a society in which there is
association of
human beings full and free development
of every individual this is what marx is
looking at
marx is also talking about social
character of the production so
i want to make this clear because i
don't want to be misunderstood i'm
answering to the question i'm trying to
answer to the question i'm trying to
list
essential elements in an organization or
a society
political economical or social elements
that for marx will make a significant
difference
compared to capitalism this does not
mean for marx that this is the end
of alienation but this means that
one society is introducing these
elements
there is an improvement and there are
less chances for you know workers
to live in the terrible condition that
we experience
under capitalism this question of the
social character of the production is
one of them
because mark said that in socialism in
what he called the associated
monoproduction you see this general
product
from the beginning not only in the end
after decals
of the market and of the capitalist
production
there is a lot about plan cooperation
okay marx is talking about this in
volume one i'm sure that you will go
back to this with other
guests in the coming weeks marx is
talking about
reckon in advance how much labor how
many means of production and means of
subsistence
subsistence can be spent etc i have no
time
but surely the idea of marx is to
contrasting this
free competition this idea of
freedom of individualism that is into
capitalism
marx is in favor of the individual marx
consider
the individual as an essential element
to alienate the alienate the society so
that the individual have space to
produce to think to interact freely
but his conception of freedom
is different from from those of
capitalists individuals are subsumed
under social production in capitalism
wage labor
okay so for marx the essential question
is the change of the production
and not only on the distribution the
society will be
much less significantly less
alienated if there is a change in the
production
and i provided some definition in the
article on
communism that this has been recently
published in the marks revival that paul
north was so kind to cite at the
beginning of this lecture
time and reduction of the working day is
another essential element
alexander of the um the alienation right
so the society
should go in that direction the
direction that
labor is liberated is free not for the
capitalists to
exploit us more so but for
us to live in a better have a better
life you know to be educated and you
know there is
ownership of the means of production for
marx means
change the lifetime of society and this
is what we are
talking when we talk about the
alienation is not the philosophical
formula
so non-alienated society is
free development i don't have time to
talk about this but there is this famous
quotation of volume three of capital
when marx is talking about
the realm of freedom and i think you
really could talk about this if you want
to martella we have 10 minutes in the
allotted time and
i'm so worried and you know i cannot see
how many questions are
there a lot of questions and very good
ones
we might not get to all of them try to
save them and send them to you
but but this seems like an important
topic
um thanks i was trying to
drink um a little bit so i'm gonna spend
um
just two minutes about this i want to
return on this
question which is still creating
problems
in my opinion in many contemporary
political
readings of marx so what is freedom for
marx max wrote about this
i find a lot of this in the preparatory
manuscript
and sometimes also in the letter even
though there are other treasures
in the notebooks in the excerpts that is
what i use for
the analysis of the last marks but this
would be the topic of another
conversation that we will learn in the
future
so if we focus on non-alienated society
so marx is writing about this
question of individual freedom living in
a non-alienated society
meant building a social organization in
which a fundamental value
was given to individuals freedom this is
me writing
now i'm going to quote from the grundris
because marx and the gundries
and not only there there are several
manuscripts in the late 50s
in which marx is very angry about the
foolishness of those socialists
marxier is thinking about french
socialists in particular
and his contemporaries like allah produ
not uh sensimon and fourier
marx had a tremendous respect for them
like for robert
owen this french socialist contemporary
to marx
the false brother of socialism marx
called them
indo grundris they want to depict
socialism as the realization of the
ideals
of bourgeois society articulated by the
french revolution
demonstrated that exchange and exchange
value etc
were good at the beginning okay
but they were perverted later by
capital it is just a question of capital
it's just a question of
distribution these are so important
political questions
the international is debating about this
a lot
the difference between marx and prudhon
is not about
misery of philosophy poverty of
philosophy
philosophy or poverty this is 1847
polymerics if you want to understand the
difference between marx and prodon
you have to go to this manuscript of the
50s both of them
and then the political struggle that is
happening in the international
when there are two different conception
about how to organize
a non-alienated society one is looking
at distribution product
one is looking at the change of the
production marks
so marx is writing into grundris free
development
under the domination of capital was
the most sweeping abolition of all
individual freedom and the complete
subjugation
of individual to social condition which
assumed the form
of objective powers indeed
of overpowering objects independent
of the individuals relating to one
another you see
that the concept is there the idea is
there and it's developing this
now capital volume three which you know
was written by marx before
capital volume one because the main
draft belongs to
1865. so this is the famous quotation
that i don't want to read right when
marx is talking about the realm of
freedom
is you know i just
cut this quotation here i will just call
your attention on this uh
very very short part because generally
it's quoted it's a 500 words it's one
full page now
the realm of freedom really begins only
where
labor determined by necessity and
external
um experience ends okay
so freedom can consist only in this
that socialized human the associated
producer
governed human metabolism with nature in
a rational way
by the way there is so much ecological
marks in this manuscript preparatory
manuscript
of capital as my colleague quaysido
as demonstrated recently after a lot of
good scholarship on the topic
and accomplishing it with the least
expenditure of energy and in conditions
most worthy and appropriate
for their human nature so this is the
quotation in which
alienation the end of alienation the
real conception of freedom
and the reduction of the working day
is they are all together so this is a
very well known
alienation i end by saying this
that this post-capitalist society of
production
together with all the progress of
technology
the reduction of the working day they
create the possibility
is not guaranteed is not the necessity
is never the end
because the contradiction will start
once again but there is a possibility
for a new social formation in which the
coercive alienated labor
imposed by capital we are talking about
wage labor of course
and subject to its roles is gradually
replaced with something that marx called
sometimes
a conscious creative activity
beyond necessity and this is what marx
called
as the real realm of freedom
the genuine realm of human freedom which
is
very different from the realm of freedom
for
capital that we have in our society
you should see me should be able to see
me if i'm not wrong
okay
thanks there's so much to say
we're just getting started you're right
that you need an all-night
seminar on alienation
i think what we should do is
thank the people who came and asked
questions there are some
still littering the chat
um filling the chat that are really
quite good how would you conceptualize
the relationship between alienation and
abstract
labor there are questions about mikhail
heinrich
an important question about feuerbach
and the development of the idea of
species being but i really do think we
need to
no i leave it good answer to this and
the answer is that you organize this
seminar with 12 lectures
and there is a lot of room and
food for thought for the colleagues that
will come after me
thank you very much we really appreciate
your time and all of this
wonderful work